this building in Manhattan's Chinatown
advertises an acupuncture clinic and
ramen delivery but FBI investigators say
in 2022 it also housed a secret police
station for China's Ministry of public
security the MPS
Liu Jang Wang and Chen jingping both U.S
citizens were arrested on Monday on
charges of helping establish and run it
the MPS officers who have been charged
today are not focused on preventing
crime rather the complaints charge these
MPS officers with engaging in
transnational repression
schemes targeting members of the Chinese
diaspora community in New York City and
elsewhere in the United States
the U.S justice department says that in
at least one case Lou and Chen tracked
down a Chinese pro-democracy activist in
California under the direction of the
Chinese National Police and the men
admitted to deleting communication with
a Chinese official
this test on Monday prosecutors also
unveiled charges against dozens of
Chinese officials for allegedly
operating a troll Farm harassing
dissidents online the Chinese Communist
party was attempting to censor
politically sensitive topics that are
unacceptable to the PRC government
including the Tiananmen Square massacre
the charges come as the doj ramps up
probes into what it calls transnational
repression by overseas governments to
intimidate political opponents in the
U.S
we cannot and will not tolerate the
Chinese government's persecution of
pro-democracy activists who have sought
refuge in this country in November
Beijing denied claims of running police
stations in the U.S saying these are
volunteer-run organizations helping
Chinese citizens with procedures like
renewing driver's licenses
a Spanish Civil Rights group Safeguard
Defenders claimed last year that there
were dozens of secret Chinese police
stations in cities around the world
enko Al Jazeera